Just before we get started,
I do want to mention another channels that I host called mega projects and mega
projects. This is a channel all about mankind's greatest achievements,
where I take a deep look at incredible buildings, project structures,
and more whether it's the world's most impressive skyscrapers,
the international space station Trenoble sarcophagus. I cover it.
All new videos come out a couple of times a week on mega projects.
Think it could be for you. Please do go head over and subscribe.
There is a link in the description below, and let's get into it.
[Inaudible].
An Island nation.
You would figure that great Britain would have its fair share of Naval heroes
after all the wooden walls.
If the Royal Navy protected the nation from invasion by various unfriendly,
continental neighbors for hundreds of years,
and then projected British strength across a globe spanning empire that the sun
never sat on. But if you asked who the greatest of Britain's Naval heroes are,
most people would give you the same answer.
The humble son of an Anglican priest,
our ratio Nelson Rose to the rank of vice Admiral while confounding and taking
apart the French and Spanish navies sent against him becoming one of the most
famous men in the world. In the process,
he did everything he could do to encourage that fame relishing in his own
success. But he was also genuinely beloved by the people who knew him well.
And particularly the sailors who served under him.
His style of leadership is cited today in business and military leadership
courses as being highly effective.
Nelson's death only added to his legend killed with almost the last bullet in
the greatest Naval battle of the age.
And one of the most famous in world history. Once again,
the role Navy had prevailed, frustrating,
the invasion plans of Napoleon and keeping British soil safe.
But the deaths of Nelson,
a Trafalgar touched off a wave of national mourning that made people question
if it was all worth it. But before we tell you about his death,
let us tell you about his fascinating yeah.
Complicated life.
Ratio. Nelson was born on September the 29th, 1758 in Norfolk, England.
His father Edmonds was the parish priest of the small village of Burnham thought
his mother Catherine's brother Maury suckling was a captain in the Royal Navy.
And younger ratio seemed destined for a Naval career from the start in 1771
aged only 12 Nelson became a midshipman reporting to the ship,
HMS reasonable captains by his uncle to be trained as a Naval officer.
In those days, it was common for teenage boys to serve on Navy ships.
In the days before military academies,
it was figured that the best teacher would be officers was firsthand.
Experience has only career was helped along by his uncle who ensured that he was
continually transferred to ships that were to see active service.
So that Nelson rapidly gains more experience than his peers and was promoted
quicker. In 1777,
he was promoted to leftenants and was assigned to HMS Laos staff,
which was about to sail to Jamaica.
And to war
[inaudible].
All of the 13 colonies of America.
It quickly blossomed into a worldwide war with the entry of France and Spain
into the conflict on the side of the Americans, the Caribbean,
where ships from all four belligerence,
routinely sails was a hotbed of Naval activity.
Nelson spent the next two years taking prizes, capturing enemy ships.
The value of which was awarded to the ship's crew, his prize money,
all the while being given more and more responsibility as his obvious talents
became apparent. He was promoted to captain in 1779 and in early 17,
80 Nelson captured a Spanish held Fort on the San Juan river in Nicaragua.
His first significant military achievements.
His career was temporarily stalled when he was struck ill with malaria and was
forced to return to Britain,
to recover Nelson soon returns to active duty and command of the HMS album mall,
which he commanded up and down the American coast until the war ended in an
American victory in 1783, after the war Nelson was sent to the Caribbean.
So act as a sort of policeman seizing,
any American ships that attempted to trade with British colonial islands,
which was illegal under the navigation acts.
It was during this time that he met Francis Fannie Nesbith.
So widow who lived on a plantation on the Island of Nevis Nelson was smitten and
her uncle offered him he large dowery to marry her.
It wasn't until after they were engaged that Nelson discovered the dowry was a
fiction.
The family wasn't worth anywhere near as much as they had claimed to make
matters. Worse.
Fannie had hit on the fact that she was in fertile and capable of having
children until after they were engaged,
breaking off the engagement would have been dishonorable for an English
gentleman. So Nelson had no choice, but to go ahead with the wedding in 1787,
the deception had soured the romance, however,
and Nelson and Fanny would become more and more estranged as time passed.
[Inaudible].
In 1788, Nelson was sent home to Britain and for five years,
he languished on shore without a command with no water flights.
That simply weren't enough ships to go round in the peacetime Navy.
And so Nelson was kept in reserve on half pay and had absolutely nothing to do,
but to tend to his affairs at home while continually badgering,
anyone he knew for a command, he got his chance in late 1792,
when the French revolutionary government eager to flex its mites to its
neighbors annex the Austrian Netherlands modern day Belgium,
which had traditionally been kept as a buffer state,
the move heightened tensions between Britain and France and in preparation for
war, the role Navy calls back its reserve offices,
including Nelson in January, 1793,
soon after France declared war and Nelson's ship sail to Gibraltar in may as
part of a fleet determined to establish British Naval supremacy in the
Mediterranean. The flashpoints of the area was the French city of tuna,
which was held by French royalists, but came under attack by the revolutionary.
Jacob ans the city appealed to the Royal Navy for help,
but eventually a launch Republican force occupied the Hills around the city and
began to bombard it into submission.
The itinerary officer in charge of bombardment was a young man named Napoleon
Bonaparte.
And so this was to be the start of his own military success story though.
No one knew it at the time. So it all fell in December and seeking a Naval base,
close to the French coast.
The fleet commander ordered Nelson to blockade the French controlled Island of
Corsica followed by an invasion in February, 1794.
After the army proved reluctant to proceed,
Nelson himself was put in command of the land forces and helped capture the city
of Bastianich.
He played an important role in ground operations for the remainder of the course
of human campaign,
using canons offloaded from Naval ships to bombard enemy positions on July the
12th,
Nelson was wounded by debris from an artillery rounds that excluded no one of
his batteries, but wound eventually it cost him his sight.
Hi.
Sure. Of course,
Nelson spent the next three years engaged in operations in the Mediterranean.
And so French victories in Italy,
head of an army commander by Napoleon forced the Royal Navy to leave their base
in Corsica and sail to Gibraltar in December, 1796,
Nelson was on the way to join them on February the first 1797,
when quite by accident,
it happens upon the Spanish fleet that had left Carter Haino Renta was headed
South to the port of kudus to eventually link up with their French allies.
Nelson's ship on scene in the fog escapes to alert the fleet commander and
John Jarvis of the Spanish movements, Jervis decided to give battle.
And on Valentine's day, the two fleets match off of Cape St. Vincent.
It was here that Nelson first distinguished himself in the eyes of the British
public and commands of the HMS captain.
He engaged three much larger Spanish ships and captured two of them by boarding
them and engaging in vicious.
Hand-to-hand combat the prize money from these two captured ships made Nelson
rich, and his heroism at capes and Vincent had made him famous.
He was now a ratio Nelson having been made and night of the bath.
And soon after the battle, he was promoted to run.
One of the first things Admiral Nelson did after his promotion was to oversee a
plan to capture the city of Santa Cruz de tenor reef and the Canary islands and
important Spanish outpost and stop over points for the Spanish treasure fleets
returning from the Americas,
the plan called for a simultaneous bombardments and as an amphibious landing.
But after two aborted attempts to storm the beach on the night of July,
the 24th, 1797 Nelson decided to lead the troops to shore itself.
The resulting battle was a disaster for the British,
the Spanish defenders were well dug in and they blasted the invading troops on
the beach with Canon VAR.
And musketry no sooner had Nelson gone to sharp than he was shot in the right
arm and collapsed back into his boat.
The basketball had smashed his humorous bone into multiple pieces and he was
rode back to his flagship to be attended to by the surgeon that's in at the time
period was barely out of the dark ages.
Germ theory was still decades away and the most common way to prevent a wounded
limb from getting gangrene and killing the victim was to amputate us.
Most of Nelson's right arm was sliced off and thrown overboard.
Most of the British force didn't fare much better when they withdrew the next
day 250 had been killed.
And there's another 128 wounded Nelson was despondent both over the failure to
capture Santa Cruz. And by the loss of his arm,
he wrote to the commanding Admiral of the Mediterranean fleets that he intended
to return home to England and dress higher. As in his words,
a left-handed Admiral will never again be considered useful.
Nelson remains in England for several months recuperating, but in March, 1798,
he went to sea again,
having been convinced that the Royal Navy had use for one arm dad Burl off to
Roland's that retirements didn't really suit him. Anyway.
He returned to the Mediterranean where he was given a squadron of 15 ships in
order to too long to intercept a French fleet that was on the move in France,
Napoleon Bonaparte had become the most important political and military figure
in the country.
His strategy for 1798 was to invade Egypt with a large army and Navy and thus
bring pressure to British occupied India.
This was in the hope that it would threaten her commercial interests and force
great person to abandon the war.
The Polian got away from Nelson after the British ships were blown off course by
a storm,
but the British soon pursued them across the Mediterranean to Alexandria.
The French army had already won a series of victories against the ruling Mamluks
and the French fleet was anchored off the coast of Alexandria in a Delta of the
Nile river in a supposedly impregnable defensive position.
But Nelson was unimpressed and moved immediately to attack.
As dusk fell on August.
The first the British ships fell upon the stationary friendships.
The French Admiral Dobros had figured that the Shoals on the flanks of his
battle line would prevent the British from getting onto his star board right
side and the dust surrounding him. So all of his sailors were ordered to man,
the port left side cannons butts Nelson's lead ships found a gap in the Shoals
and suddenly the French found themselves under attack from both sides,
darkness fell,
but the scene was illuminated by the battle raging in the Nile Delta cannons.
Belched out flames from all sides and started several fires,
including one that's in Gulf with the French flagship Loreal.
This exploded when the flames reached the gunpowder magazine killing Admiral to
braise, Admiral Nelson was wounded for the third time in his Korea,
a flesh wounds that he quickly had bandaged.
And then he returns to oversee the battle overwhelmed by the amounts of British
cannons, brought to bear on them.
The friendships began to surrender as Dawn broke on August. The second,
the battle was for all intents and purposes over the French fleet was completely
destroyed out of 17 ships that began the battle four were banned and nine were
captured. The French suffered 3,500 casualties to the British 900.
The battle has great strategic consequences for the war.
It traps Napoleon's army in Egypt forcing the general to return to France
without his troops. He never trusted the Navy again,
and this mistrust would weigh heavily in his future military decisions.
Great Britain.
Meanwhile had gained complete dominance of the seas around the conflict zone and
advantage that hold for the rest of the war.
Nelson's victory at the battle of the Nile made him a national hero heads of
state from all over Europe sent him accolades and he reveled in the attention
for all these many virtues.
Nelson was rather vain and a shameless self promoter. For instance,
when shortly afterward reached London of his victory,
he was given the title Barron Nelson of the Nile and Nelson was insulted to
this.
He was only given a near Baron Mary instead of a more prestigious title shortly
after the battle of the Nile Nelson sail to Naples to refit his squadron.
He was fated by the Neapolitan RA court and was a guest of British ambassador.
So William Hamilton Nelson had briefly met. So William and his wife,
Emma in 1793, but he was a far different man. Now he was Scott.
He was blind in one eye, missing an arm and internationally renowned.
Emma Hamilton was 35 years younger than her husband and was considered one of
the most beautiful and intelligent women of her day during Nelson stay in
Naples. He and Emma felt deeply in love with each other.
And soon we're carrying on an affair that the entire world seemed to know about.
The strange part was that not only was it apparent that so William was aware of
his wife's affair with Nelson, but he was surprisingly open-minded about it.
Considering the time he lived in the three lived together in Naples.
And when Hamilton was recalled home to England, Nelson returned as well.
And the three set up together at a house in London,
much to the fury of Nelson's wife, Fanny around Christmas,
1800 funny gave her husbands and ultimatum to choose Emma or her and well
Nelson chose his mistress. The two never lived together, right?
[Inaudible].
On January the first 1801 Nelson was promoted to vice Admiral and was sent on a
new assignment to the Baltic seat. Denmark,
tired of Britain blockading her ports to stop French trade had allied itself
with Prussia, Sweden, and Russia.
In order to break the blockade of the Royal Navy Nelson was sent as part of a
fleet to do break up this league of arms neutrality.
This threatens British Naval supremacy in Europe,
Nelson convinced his superior Admiral pockets.
You allow him to take a dozen ships of the line into Copenhagen Harbor and
attack the Danish fleas before they had time to join up with the Swedish and
Russian fleets Nelson attacks on April. The second,
the battle didn't start out well for the British three ships ran a grounds early
in the battle promising Admiral Parker to signal the retreat,
but Nelson who had a better grasp of the situation than Ponka pocketed decided
to continue the attack in a bit of his trademark,
which he held up his telescope to his blind. Diane said,
I honestly can't see the signal.
The battle soon turned in the favor of the British as they destroyed three
Dennis' ships and captured and burned a dozen more Nelson gold for a true
switch.
The Danes accepted the destruction of the Danish fleet together with the sudden
death of saw Peter of the first of Russia Bach to the ends of the league and
Nelson returned home to receive more accolades.
He was now via counts Nelson of the Nile and considered the country's foremost
Naval hero in October, 1801, great Britain and France signals.
The peace of amnion ending the war Nelson spends the next two years in Britain
living with William and Emma Hamilton and touring the country with him.
Emma had given birth to a daughter.
Her ratio that everyone knew was Nelson's illegitimate daughter runs the
unconventional family, all lived together at a country estate and sorry.
And also William died in April, 1803 a month later, born again,
broke out and Nelson was back at sea.
[Inaudible].
One was appointed commander of the Mediterranean fleet and given the pride of
the Royal Navy HMS victory as this flagship, these orders,
weren't a blockade to nor the French Navy under the commands of Admiral Pierre
Sharpeville Nerf was at Hancock.
It was essential to keep the French ships from escaping the blockade and moving
North to the English channel where they could help Napoleon.
Now emperor of the French invaded great Britain for two years,
Nelson and Villanova played a cat and mouse game with each other,
a series of back and forth maneuvers that saw Nelson at one point,
chase Seville nerve all the way across the Atlantic to the West Indies.
And then back again in August, 1895,
Nelson resounds briefly to England on leave. He was cheered everywhere.
He went much to his delight in September word came the allied French and Spanish
fleets have combined together at the Spanish port of CodeHS Nelson. You know,
it was time to return to see he departed on board victory on September the 14th,
after saying goodbye to his beloved,
Emma Nelson arrived at CodeHS on September the 27th and spent most of the next
month preparing for the battle. He was sure was to come. Meanwhile,
his French counterpart felt was feeling the heat from Napoleon.
The emperor was angry that his Admiral wouldn't engage the British fleet and
breakouts of the blockade at cadets. He sent a replacement to Overland,
to kudus, to take command of the fleet.
Phil nerve in an effort to stave off the humiliation of being relieved of
command, decided to sail out before his replacement arrived on October the 20th,
the 33 ships of the Franco Spanish fleet sailed out of cadets were spotted as by
British scout,
frigates who quickly moved to inform Nelson when October the 21st Nelson moved
as 27 ships to engage the enemy off the coast of Cape Trafalgar up as 1145,
he prepared to engage.
He ordered a signalman to signal the rest of the ships in the fleet.
England expects that every man will do his duty.
A great share went off throughout the British fleet.
Nelson was truly beloved by the many commanders and a time when Naval officers
were expected to be strict disciplinarians.
The points of cruelty towards the common sailor Nelson Ghana respects with
affection and kindness Nelson's battle plan was simple.
He meant to close with a Franco Spanish fleet as quickly as possible,
cuts their battle line into three pieces and engage the enemy and ship to ship
combat, which he was sure he would be.
Victoria sat due to the superior training is going to recruit.
He splits his force into two squadrons. One led by himself, a board victory,
and to the other led by his second in command.
Admiral Collingwood bought the role sovereign with Alyssa wind to speed that
progress.
The British ships slowly moved towards the allied line all while on the fire
from the French and Spanish ships. Finally, after almost an hour,
victory passed between two friendships and fought a devastating broadside.
Other ships followed and general Melay ensued.
Victory found herself engaging the friendship.
Redoubtable the French screw has largely abandoned their cannons and were
massing on deck to try and board the Admiral's flagship until they were cut
apart by the cannon fire of a passing British ship.
All the while the murderous fire poured down from the redoubtable Moston rigging
from saying the station's up there with muskets Nelson had forbidden his
captains from doing this worried about the sails catching on fire.
Thus unhampered,
the front sharp shooters cars pick their targets well and Nelson standing on the
quarter deck in his distinctive uniform made very perfect target at around 1:00
PM an hour into the battle.
Nelson was shot the bullets entering through his shoulder blade and severing his
spinal cord.
The Admiral collapsed to the DAC recognizing immediately that the wound was
fatal.
He was carried below deck and made comfortable as there was nothing that the
doctor could do for him.
Nelson live long enough to hear that yet another spectacular victory.
It was his, the French and Spanish had lost 22 ships. The British had lost none.
Thank God I've done.
My duty Nelson said Admiral died at four 30 at the age of 47.
[Inaudible].
Celebration of the victory of the battle of Trafalgar.
Instead the death of Admiral Nelson touched off a period of profound national
mourning and great Britain that wouldn't be seen again until the death of
princess. Diana, nearly 200 years later,
Nelson's body was returned to England and given a state funeral at Simple's
cathedral in London,
thousands of people lined the funeral routes and packs the pews of the cathedral
to say goodbye to their hero. One person not in attendance. However,
was Emma Hamilton.
Nelson had neglected to amend as well to include Emma and her ratio.
Aaron's although he begged the country to take care of them before he died.
Nelson's brother who inherited most of his estate was completely uninterested in
helping her.
The British public may have been willing to overlook Nelson's affair because of
his status. As a national hero. After his death,
Emma was branded and adulterer was shunned by her former friends.
She died in 1815 at the age of 49 deeply in debt and suffering from a number of
health problems. Her daughter with Nelson,
a ratio lived a quiet life as a reverend's wife and raised 10 children living
until 1881.
Nelson had so many places and things named after him that it would be impossible
to list them all the most famous of these is Trafalgar square in London.
One of the most popular tourist attractions in the city located prominently in
the square is they 145 foot 44 meter granite column topped with a
statue of the man who will likely forever be known as Britain's most beloved
sailor. So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe brand new video several times per week, and as always,
thank you for watching.